digamos que manejo algún tipo de fondo
de pensiones y tengo un billón de
dólares que quiero invertir en algún
lugar entonces busco y busco y encuentro
a esta compañía llamada la compañía a la
cual necesita prestados un billón de
dólares entonces yo estoy yo soy la
indicada y está dispuesto a pagar un 10%
en intercambio por el préstamo así que
si les doy a estos cuates mi billón de
dólares entonces dentro de un año
ellos me regresarán más el 10% de
interés pero hay un problema el problema
aquí es que las agencias de calificación
vamos a usar a moody a las que en teoría
deberían ser independientes las agencias
de calificación le dieron a la agencia a
una calificación w y este es un fondo de
pensiones así que solo debo invertir en
lo más seguro debo invertir con
seguridad solo debo invertir en las
cosas que tengan de calificación doble
así que aquí entra un personaje de
american international líder mundial de
seguros y servicios financieros lo cual
desde la perspectiva de moody's
tiene una doble a entonces ahí se puede
decir el fondo de pensión mira
prestarles el dinero y lo que haremos es
entrar a una permuta de incumplimiento
crediticio y lo que es es una forma de
seguro de ese 10% cada año porque no nos
das a nosotros el 1% en esta jerga
financiera a eso se refieren a 100
puntos base ahora en intercambio por
esos 100 puntos base que puedes verlos
como primas de seguro vamos a asegurar
lo escribo asegurar que si por cualquier
razón motivo circunstancia la compañía
tiene incumplimiento de pago entonces tú
nos puedes dar el título de deuda y
nosotros en cambio te regresamos tu
billón de dólares lo puedes ver desde el
punto de vista de la pensión esto suena
genial para ellos están obteniendo un 9
por ciento de interés 10% menos un por
ciento le van a prestar una compañía
calificada w pero es como prestarle a
una compañía de doble-a porque mientras
que sea bueno con el dinero el fondo de
pensión obtendrás de vuelta su dinero
de otra manera entonces me das el título
de deuda y si las cosas salen mal yo te
regreso tu billón de dólares pero
observa las cosas se ponen medidas
sospechosas porque la compañía aeg no
tiene que hacer nada lo interesante de
las permutas de incumplimiento
crediticio a veces referidas a cdc
xerez default swaps lo interesante es
que a pesar de ser seguros no están
regulados como seguros entonces típico
cuando una compañía de seguros quiere
asegurar algo ellos deben guardar algo
de dinero en caso de que si suceda la
razón por la cual aseguran eso las
permutas de incumplimiento crediticio no
fueron reguladas de esa manera entonces
ahí se puede seguir con su plan sin
tener que guardar dinero ahí se puede
hacer esto una y otra y un millón de
veces ellos así viven a gusto entonces
tú puedes imaginar es buen dinero el que
están obteniendo mientras nadie está
fallando sus pagos pero si empieza el
fallo de pago se termina la fiesta para
dije hay que estar en problemas y todos
los que querían tener seguro el acuerdo
con aeg quizás no sea como ellos piensan